I have an endlessly utterly completely
amazing story for you Fox News had a
fake Swedish defense advisor on to talk
about Donald Trump's fake Swedish
terrorist attack comment this is
stunningly epic now as a reminder Donald
Trump recently referred to quote what
happened in Sweden some kind of
terrorist attack or violence or
something which of course didn't exist
okay here's Trump talking about that
recently you look at what's happening in
Germany you look at what's happening
last night in Sweden Sweden who would
believe this Sweden they took in large
numbers they're having problems like
they never thought possible so that
never happened ultimately Trump tweeted
that he heard about the story from none
other than Fox News and we showed you
that tweet when we covered the story
last week so what happens next
Fox News specifically bill o'reilly
decides to follow up on this big story
blah blah blah so they bring on a guy by
the name of Nils
Bilt captioned on The O'Reilly Factor as
a Swedish defense and national security
adviser okay you can see that if you're
watching here this is the way that Nils
built was presented on Fox News's
O'Reilly Factor the guy was fake Swedish
military and foreign affairs officials
actual ones from Sweden said they have
no idea who this guy is they've never
heard of them they know nothing about
him of course built showed up and did
what we all expected him to do linked
immigration to crime and social problems
in Sweden was sad about what he
described as Swedish liberal
close-mindedness about the downsides of
welcoming newcomers he said quote we are
unable in Sweden to socially integrate
these people and then it all fell apart
Swedish defense ministry and the Swedish
Defense Ministry and Foreign Office told
the newspaper Dagens nyet er they know
nothing of built we have a quote from
Swedish defense University leadership
professor Robert Agnel who said he is
not in any way a known quantity in
Sweden and has never been part of the
Swedish debate Johan Wieck Turan
an actual Swedish intelligence and
security adviser said he's never heard
of Nils built built didn't respond on
Saturday to email enquiries but someone
who picked up the phone at his company
agreed to relay a message telling
doggins
theater the newspaper on Friday that he
was that Nils built was a us-based
independent analyst and that it was Fox
News who chose to describe him as a
Swedish defense and national security
advisor Fox News said Bill O'Reilly is
expected to address this further on
tonight's program even better than
whatever his title is reports suggest
that Nils built hasn't been in Sweden
for nearly 25 years what on earth does
he even know about this what do you
think we'll get a retraction and apology
from Fox News maybe they're often very
reluctant to apologize or attract
anything I mean when you watch this
interview it kind of seems like maybe
the guy is choosing his words very
deliberately speaking very slowly and
that may come across as he as if he's
like an intellectual or at least there's
like a pseudo intellectual careful guy
but maybe now we just realized he didn't
know what he was talking about at all
the damage is done though right I mean
like when Kellyanne Conway showed up and
talked about the Bowling Green massacre
committed by Iraqi refugees which was
totally made up people believed it they
integrated it into their sort of general
understanding of the situation they act
as if it's real and that probably also
is a factor when it comes to niels built
but hey if you're worried don't worry
any day now we're going to get leaks
from an anonymous source which of course
trump is against unless it's good for
him which will confirm that Fox News is
actually great and reliable but CNN is
the fake news we obviously just brought
this guy on to give some validation to
Donald Trump's assertions yeah and some
things that he says I mean you can kind
of leave that up for debate but they're
so clearly was not a terrorist attack in
Sweden that day I mean how are you able
to even argue that and not to mention
this guy clearly is not what his title
on-screen claims him to be a Swedish
defense and national security adviser is
this a the first fake guest of 2017 that
we've seen maybe that we've seen luleå
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum
david pakman.com slash read it that's re
d di t nearly 3,000 of our viewers and
listeners now participating on our
reddit discussion forum a lot of good
stuff a lot of scandals related to pat
actually on our reddit discussion forum
one related to coffee and you know it's
there's a lot of crazy stuff happening
on almost as many scandals as the trump
administration yeah
pat has almost as many scandals in 2017
as trump does which is shocking because
trump has a lot david pakman.com slash
read it we'll take a break attorney Mike
Papantonio joins me next today's show is
brought to you by go daddy where you can
buy your own domain name build a website
or use any of Go Daddy's business tools
you can save 30 percent at Tri
godaddy.com slash David GoDaddy has
actually been the official host of the
David Pakman show website for many many
many years the 24/7 customer support has
been a very good thing for us I've
called them at really odd times when
we've had website issues and they are
always available they are the largest
domain registrar and whether you have a
new idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to GoDaddy
they can do it all 13 million customers
try it and get 30% off at try go
daddy.com slash david